so hi my name is David Michigan lead
designer on paradox north I'm working on
this title magica wizard wars so I'll
just walk you through a bit of the new
stuff that's in here right so we've
added a new game mode to magic a wizard
rules it's a dual game mode if you
haven't heard anything about magica it's
a spell casting action pvp game
basically you have fantastic little
elements down here eight of them you low
charge them up or queue them up and then
you launch them off into a spectacular
spell as you see down here the new thing
about this is the new game mode it's a
dual game of where you play one on one
just like this epic wizard duel thing
and i think i'm up now so i'm going to
put a ward on myself i'm going to use
fire make a fire spray death beams if i
combine earth and fire i do a fireball i
can do a flaming duck beam i can do a
chilling lightning strike I can throw up
some barriers and some minds oops and
sorry it's quite intense now that the
key thing of this game if you haven't
tried it before it's also that everyone
has the same everyone has the same
abilities we look different but that's
because we equip different sort of
equipment that sort of boosts how good
you are at the different elements that
it's just side grades so it doesn't give
you any special and unique abilities Wow
everybody can do the same thing so it's
very very skilled based it's down to how
well you actually play
ah
no i wanna i will not defeat him know so
everybody has the same tools available
and now i lost because the other guy was
better than me not because it was a
different clause was a different he had
better equipment or anything like that
one of the other key differences from
the with this gate is that the original
game mode we did was team-based and on a
much larger map and by putting the same
spell system into a more tighter area it
really changed the whole metagame around
it the complexity at the spell system
means that things like crowd control and
crowd control etc becomes much more
important here than it does in
the original wizard warfare gleam of
which is steam based all right so now I
have not received enough magic focus to
actually summon depth so i'll just do
this on whoever comes in next right no
this is a meteor shower
so we also have a very strict rock paper
sissors system that if you shoot a beam
into a shield it will reflect back and
knock you back just like a repost in a
fighting game or a block in a fighting
game we can throw barriers that that
block projectiles and we can throw up
these Oh thunderstorm need to protect
myself against lightning
no I that would be a tie yes because
both died in the same time so this is
the front end you see your wizard here
you can see what he has equipped we have
a gear screen where you can just equip
the different stuff you have are you see
all the gear we have effects the
elements in different ways so now I
equip like the wind widows winter hat it
makes you strong and Colton's but we
don't have an operating system we have a
side grade system so there's not a
single upgrade that's better than
something else it's just different so if
you're good with cold you're
automatically weaker in the water so you
get a strength and you're getting
weakens at the same time and it enables
you to sort of specialize so now I'm
going all old Death Magic here so I am
lots of death that means I'm very good
with that magic but I'm very very
vulnerable to fire and it becomes sort
of a meta game in here that someone can
see how I look know that I am strong
with death week with fire and protect
themselves accordingly in the store I
mean we're doing weekly updates as well
so we've added quite a bit of context
here so there's there is a robe and a
look for for each of the eight elements
that we have also different sort of
stops ah look beautiful so flipper robe
for being good with water green yep the
Druids gain for being good with life and
a flintlock pistol that you can shoot it
to repellents we also have like
different sort of weapons everything
from small rusting knives with very fast
special attacks up to like Spears and
and heavy weapons like access that have
slow and heavy special attacks and range
special it sounds so this has been meet
David this Hagen the designer presenting
a bit of magic of wizard wars we're
currently in early access on Steam or
closed alpha and we're looking at open
beta sometime in late
thank you